quand vous mangez au resto il y a
parfois rien de plus relou et on le sait
qu'un enfant qui pleure à côté allez
c'est comme dans l'avion tu sais que si
t'as pas de chance et que tu te
retrouves dans l'avion en 22 c'est et
qu'en 22h ou en 21 derrière tu as un
enfant et tu connais quand l'enfant il
te met des coups tout le truc comme ça
je vous dis c'est une énorme tasse qui
l'a déjà eu ça bien sûr
mais le pire c'est quand il est pas
rendu de l'enfant parce que tu sais que
tu as déjà tout le monde et que tu peux
te péter à tout moment dans la vie non
mais c'est obligé tu vois que tu dis
c'est sûr et certain pire c'est les
parents qui assume qu'ils disent ah bah
alors s'il commence maintenant on est
foutu pour tout le
volant
on va lui dire tout de suite
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vraiment beaucoup plus petit je me
rappelle je me mets l'avion il déconnait
un peu et après c'est WAM je dirais même
les veux je te demande
on pleurait de
règles
je te jure
c'était incroyable quoi qu'est-ce qu'il
y a un support on parlait d'éducation
positive
Singapour ils ont trouvé une solution
ils peuvent vous faire payer plus cher
si vos enfants faut trop de bruit au
resto non c'est incroyable ou pas
c'est une très bonne journée
de Singapour c'est 7 euros en plus si
votre enfant a fait trop de bruit
pendant le repas c'est le principe mis
en place par ce restaurant de Singapour
depuis début septembre est-ce que ça
marche est-ce que les parents ont
vraiment du payer la taxe le restaurant
dit que le nombre de plaintes à
drastiquement chuté depuis
l'instauration de l'attaque même si sur
Google il a été inondé d'avis négatif de
la part de parents qui eurent la
discrimination
voilà
les enfants ont besoin de s'exprimer au
restaurant
Bernard il y a des enfants qui ont des
problèmes il y a des enfants qui ne
maîtrisent pas des enfants qui ont des
projets
se taper les enfants il peut pas les
garder à la maison c'est dur non non
c'est très emmerdant ma chérie tu vas
dîner tranquillement dans un truc et tu
as les enfants qui ont à côté tu as
envie de dîner tranquille alors
pour moi ça me fait beaucoup non non moi
je suis pas d'accord c'est comme dans
les hôtels parfois
donc tu veux quoi il y a Clara qui parle
aux États-Unis il y a des hôtels des des
piscines des restaurants réservés aux
adultes
les enfants sont des des êtres humains
comme les autres il s'est passé moi cet
été je t'en Espagne
je vais dans un hôtel et ils disent mes
enfants ils peuvent pas aller dans une
piscine et une piscine vous pouvez pas
aller c'est vrai j'ai appelé responsable
de l'hôtel
tout de suite l'hôtel tout de suite
ou mes enfants se baignent dans cette
piscine ou je quitte l'hôtel
non pas du tout non mais parce que ils
étaient dégoûté sans rigoler il y a une
piscine pourrie et là il y a une piscine
de ouf et que il y a que des yaves bah
oui mais justement
il a fait sortir tous les vieux de la
piscine il a dit les enfants vont se
baigner bref
alors vous savez ce que j'ai fait après
[Rires]
les maisons sont des amours dans la
piscine
grave
en fait c'est pas une question
d'éducation donc du coup un enfant très
bien éduqué peut aller au resto mais il
peut avoir un problème une crise et tout
donc moi je trouve ça pas bien de donner
une amende parce que qui va dire qui va
dire ok aujourd'hui il est allé trop
loin c'est quoi il y a même à partir de
quand c'est le barème
il faut pas forcer les parents à devoir
aller dehors ou quitter le restaurant
parce que exceptionnellement il y a une
crise mais non malheureusement en France
interdit c'est le code pénal c'est la
discrimination